Hey
I know I know you can't believe your
eyes it is the one and only mass Pinto
right here in the flesh well not where
you are but here in my living room I am
in the flesh
please make any sense I just wanted to
make one of these videos that I haven't
done in a while I'm talk to you about
something that's kind of been on my mind
quite a bit recently actually that is
going to lead to some differences that
this channel is going to go into in the
following weeks months maybe even years
depending on how successful these new
ventures are but first off I have some
things in order I don't know if you've
seen the subscriber count for this
channel recently but we recently passed
50,000 subscribers
50,000 subscribers and subscribers that
is absolutely I don't have any words I
don't have any words I can rattle it off
in the amount of cities that I look
around that don't even have enough
people in them to match the number of
subscribers that I have on my channel
that entire concept is just
mind-boggling and at this point I have
no idea how far we can go we being you
and me because that's how this works you
view me making content for you and if
you like that content they'll make more
of it etc etc and speaking of content
that's what I wanted to get into talking
about today but I just wanted to take
some time and say I don't even know what
to do with that information five zero
zero zero zero subscribers is just way
more than I ever thought possible so
thank you each and every one of you
thank you so much for contributing what
you have to making this channel what it
is now writing on that note I have some
things I want to talk about real quick
first up on my agenda is that Zelda /
game theories in general are difficult
and limited so what I'm trying to say is
I do theories right all of you watching
that notice and by the way if you're new
to my channel Mike
content and this is the first time that
you are seeing anything that has to do
with message in a minute boy are you in
for a surprise but anyway back to the
problem with Zelda theories as far as
content goes to be honest with you a
theory is not necessarily new content it
is new content but it's not based off of
content that I made if that makes sense
when you are a theorist like myself and
you are making theories for people to
watch you are restrained to working
within you know the material that's
already been made so in this case the
games that have already been made the
Canon that has already been put out
there and furthermore you're restrained
to trying to do something that nobody
else has done before and when you're
talking about theories specifically
Zelda theories there's been a lot done
so far no I'm not trying to say that I'm
out of content or that I'm out of Theory
ideas I definitely still have a whole
lot to send your way but on that note I
never intended for mass antena bandit as
a channel to just be theories or just
the Zelda or just B's held of theories
which is what I am so far I'm saying all
that to say I'm gonna be branching out
now here's where I'm getting into the
announcements portion of this entire
whatever you want to call this kind of
video that I'm doing here one second I I
took some notes here let me adjust my
glasses and it in check real quick so
first up the first of which is I'm gonna
be rolling out game reviews so if you've
seen channels like peanut butter gamer
or John Shawn they have these grand or
even video game dumb they have these
grandeur videos that they will put up
about reviewing a game or a series of
games and I think I want to do that I've
always wanted to do that's actually kind
of why about this camera right here and
I have kind of a makeshift set up going
right now it's kind of weird I got like
a Batman hat over there an ocarina I
know what I'm doing I promise but anyway
I'm gonna branch out into reviewing
games and obviously I'm gonna start with
Zelda games first and foremost if you've
been on my channel for very long and
you've gone to the post well I had a
poll the other day about what Zelda game
you guys would want me to review first
somebody put in the comments that I
should do the Zelda games in
chronological
and another comment said that I should
actually review the Zelda games in the
order that they were released in real
life so like starting with The Legend of
Zelda from 1987 okay just just forget
about that but as far as what model I'm
going to use for reviewing Zelda games I
think I'm gonna go with in real life the
order in which the Zelda games were all
released so I'm gonna start with the
original Legend of Zelda I'm gonna play
it through obviously I'm gonna script
something and then I'm going to just put
together a video it's gonna have my face
in it it's gonna be great I hope you
guys are looking forward to that and a
whole bunch of other game reviews that
are going to be coming in the future the
second thing that I am rolling out which
I'm actually really excited and super
scared to do is I'm going to be opening
up a second account once I hear all of
you asking well it's not for necessarily
a different purpose it is going to be
the same channel in Spanish so that's
gonna be really exciting it's gonna be
managed by a different company and we'll
see how it goes next up I am going to be
coming out with some merch so this has
been something that's been requested for
a little bit and that I've had on my
mind for a little while and actually in
the back of my head I always told myself
if I hit 50,000 subscribers then I'll
come up with some merch anyway so yeah
I'm gonna be coming up with some merch I
don't really know what it's gonna be
just yet but I'm gonna have you know
maybe a couple of mid-grade like maybe a
shirt or something like that but it's
mostly just gonna be little knickknacks
and stuff you know if hey if you guys
are interested in that and you want to
see more of that let me know in the
comments below what kinds of ideas you
have about that what kinds of things
you'd be interested in and I'll be sure
to take it into consideration and that
actually leads me into my next point
which is should be as of this upload
right now should be um I have now gone
live with channel memberships now this
is something that's really exciting and
it's kind of new to YouTube in general
it hasn't really been out there for that
long I think it's only like a year or
two old the entire system but it's
really cool because a lot of people who
want to take a step forward and either
one want to support a creator and other
means then you know with just a view
because obviously people will understand
you know how youtubers work and how we
get paid and stuff like that
probably understand that we get paid
from ad revenue and ad revenue comes
from views so every time that somebody
watches a video you know skips the ad
whatever that is actually a little bit
of money in YouTube pocket of which a
certain percentage goes to my pocket but
especially when it comes to trying times
like the one that we're in now you
better I'll be washing your hands by the
way if you don't I'm gonna come find you
and I'm gonna make you wash your hands
but anyway especially in the trying
times that we're in like right now
companies are reorienting what they're
spending away from marketing which pulls
ads away from YouTube which makes fewer
ads available which makes pricing just
go down in general so right now
youtubers are hurting pretty bad I'm
lucky enough to be considered an
essential employee I work at a hospital
as some of you know not in hospital work
necessarily on my teeth so I plug
keyboards and stuff like that but I am
an essential employee so I'm still on
payroll with the company I'm still okay
I'm making some money and yes I'm
washing my hands and even wearing a mask
but anyway what's this got to do with
memberships well it's a more direct way
to support a creator and what's cool
about it is you get tons of perks for it
too if you've ever been on a youtube
video watch page and you're scrolling
through the comments and you see these
people that have badges by their names
which is just a little cutesy icon by
the person's name who's commenting that
lets people know that they are a
supporter of that channel and also gives
the comments priority that's a channel
membership other perks include besides
the badges by your name whenever you
comment in a video unique emoji to use
when you are commenting on videos
discounts on merchandise which like I
said I'm gonna be rolling out pretty
soon access to Members Only posts and
some potential Members Only videos that
I might be going live with depending on
how many of you want to get on board
with this and it did cross my mind that
I have quite a few patrons who support
me over on patreon and while I
absolutely I I appreciate so much what
you guys do for me on patreon if you
currently support me on patreon and
you'd like to still support me in
YouTube feel free to transfer that and
it on
patreon come over to YouTube you'll get
benefits here you'll get access to my
members only stuck here and it's all
within YouTube which as we know is
benevolent and amazing as far as
crediting people who are supporting the
channel I will be crediting just like I
do at the end of my videos you know my
thank you to patrons I'll also have my
Thank You Tube my channel members so
it'll be a very similar support system
only thing is it's here in YouTube
instead of going over to patreon and
because it's in YouTube there will be a
lot of benefits that you can read in
YouTube so that'll be a really nice
system that I'll get rolled out anyway
that's really all that I had today I
just want to go over kind of some of the
issues that I'm running into as a
theorist and then of course I wanted to
thank you guys for 50,000 subscribers
and finally disgust channel memberships
which are live right now so guys that's
all as always huge thanks to all my
patreon and potential new channel
members be sure to LIKE this video if
you enjoyed and if you are new to me and
this is the first time you've ever seen
me check out some of the things that
I've got be sure to subscribe for a lot
of these new things that I'm going to be
coming out with and all my theories and
just the Nintendo stuff in general
that's coming thank you guys so much for
everything you do I've taken up too much
of your time
so please do me a big favor and have a
great rest of your day this is massive
tentative annex signing out peace
[Music]
you
[Music]